le cirque d'hiver à paris fête son 150e
anniversaire une étude récente a montré
que le cirque se porte à nouveau très
bien en france en tout cas il continue
de faire rêver les jeunes les moins
jeunes
c'est ainsi qu'hier soir le comédien
michel serrault à réaliser son rêve le
plus cher paraît-il faire le clown
michel mompontet lance iront frédéric
d'heure hier soir à paris soirée de fête
au cirque d'hiver
un cirque d'hiver illuminés comme un
gâteau géant d'anniversaire le certaines
hiver en effet 150 ans cent cinquante
ans et une farandole d'histoire
d'histoire et de légendes et à soirée de
gala parterre de stars enfants d'un soir
et parrain de prestige
on n'a pas tous les jours cent cinquante
ans
place au cirque phrase traditionnelle en
ouverture de numéros traditionnels mais
voilà un soir de fête
les athlètes de la barre fixe honteux
renfort inattendu
et bien messieurs
non ce pas
nous auraient pas compris
mais s'il a voulu le faire son numéro
michel serrault parent d'un soir il a
fait un grand un très grand numéro de
clown
et l'homme volant de ces nuages a pu
assister à un extraordinaire un
désopilant numéro le ventriloque
vous n'avez qu'à ouvrir la bouche quand
je vous présenterai la main leur
avait-il dit
rires émotions ça fait cent cinquante
ans que ça dure au cirque d'hiver